back to what we were discussing earlier
with quarterbacks maybe wanting more
than what the team will pay and where
does it all lead there's been a
narrative that's popped up in recent
days regarding the Rams in Jared Goff
and this was really accelerated big cat
in the aftermath of Carson Wentz taken
one spot after golf in the 2016 draft
getting his contract
when will Gough did his the Rams are
waiting cam and demo off the Rams CEO
said that last Friday we're not on the
same timetable as the Eagles in the
interim and in the aftermath you've had
on three different occasions now by my
count Shaun McVeigh the coach of the
Rams making it abundantly clear the
Jared Goff is his guy then he's not a
system quarterback he is the system that
there's a 0% chance that he's not going
to get the contract extension he's
worthy of now all the praise that's
being heaped on Jared Goff could drive
up his price tag but the phrase worthy
of tells me there are limits to what the
Rams will pay and that's what I keep
coming back to until we know what Jared
Goff wants and until we know what the
Rams will pay we don't know whether or
not there's a gap there but just like
with Prescott in the Cowboys there's a
chance that wig off in the Rams that's
gonna be the first scenario where the
impasse lands it can't be resolved and
the quarterback moves on and the team
moves on now my only question to you is
Sean McVeigh keeps praising Gerry Goffin
we automatically think contract contract
contract even though he has two years
more under contract because they picked
up that fifth year option is it contract
or is it Sean McVeigh trying to boost
the confidence of his quarterback after
an absolutely putrid offensive
performance in this Super Bowl and I
think a lot of the blame goes to Sean
McVeigh as much as Jared Goff and they
both will stand up there and take that
blame and tell you that it was awful and
tell you they made mistakes so they
probably haunts them so I think it's
more Sean McVeigh you can't you can't
change everyone's mind from what they
saw in the Super Bowl until you kick off
week one right but at least you can try
to boost your quarterback up and talk
about him in you know and praise him in
the media to try to get the narrative
off of what the Rams didn't do in the
Superbowl and on to what they will do
this next year I
agree with you completely the problem is
those things Sean McVeigh may be saying
now become the quotes that Ryan toner
Jared Goff say Junt will be reading back
to the rams negotiate and you put kevin
dem off in a situation where you gotta
say hey Sean McVeigh was just trying to
boost your guy he really didn't mean all
of that but that's the point how much of
it does Sean McVeigh really mean big cat
how much of it is boosting the guy's ego
and how much of it is real and to Sean
McVeigh deep down does he believe he
can't do it without golf or does he
think he could do it with somebody else
I think McVeigh has enough confidence in
himself that he believes if he had to he
could do it with someone else but I
think Sean McVeigh is an honest guy so
you're basically saying Sean McVeigh is
lying but you're just saying it you just
said it you said he's doing it to boost
his confidence yeah I know dad's only
doing this contract you are then taking
it to the contracts of and that's what
I'm saying
it has nothing does I I know you think
that it's going to be part of the
contract negotiation I guarantee you a
quote that Sean McVeigh if u s-- walk in
there and say well what do you what do
you think this is like you know a
negotiation with an elementary school
kid well you said this you know six
months you can't quote your coach and
say you owe us this money that's how it
work this guy that's how the negotiation
works tonyia you may not like it I'm
telling you I've been doing this for 20
years now youyou may not like it but
that's what agents do that's why one of
the cardinal rules is you don't
excessively praise your guys in the
media because then they are gonna try to
jam it up your you know what sideways
when it's time to negotiate with them
here's all the great things you've said
about my guy that's why I think you
should pay my guy that's what agents do
that's what they do that's I'm not
saying that's what I'm not saying that's
not what agents do of course that's what
they do I'm saying that it doesn't
really end up mattering at the end of
the day like it doesn't matter what Sean
McVeigh says it matters what Jared Goff
does on the field and that's really what
it comes down to and if Sean McVeigh
look do you think that if you asked Sean
McVeigh ugv shot him for truth serum he
wants Jared golf to be worthy of
ever contract you're talking about he
wants him to perform to a level where
the Rams have to resign him for a max
deal Iraq so it's it's kind of
counterintuitive you're like well don't
say anything nice about your quarterback
they want him to perform to a level
where he can hit you the franchise guy
but big cat if they're sold on him
shouldn't they just sign him now
cuz if they're right the price is only
gonna go up no I I don't I don't
disagree with that you know it's that
comes down more to what they're willing
to do and are they are they may be a
little scared of the Todd Gurley thing
where they sign Todd Gurley to a
contract extension before his - you know
his contract was up and now they're
getting burned a little bit because who
knows what his knees about obviously
running back is different than
quarterback but I mean I would assume
they're talking when they say they're
not talking I assume they're talking and
I assume they're trying to get a deal
done in the next you know whatever it
may be
3-4 months because Carson wants this guy
is the same as Jared Goff sky and
they're gonna probably get together and
they're going to try to figure this out
whether it's the Rams in golf the
Cowboys in Prescott the the Chiefs and
Patrick mahomes the Browns of Baker may
feel there's an endless list of young
quarterbacks who will be due for new
contracts I think I do agree at some
point at some point there's gonna be an
impasse and it's gonna get very
interesting I'm actually gonna write
myself a note cuz I know we're talking
about dak again so I'm gonna write
myself a note Mike he got me fired up
you got you you know what was that was
like my first hit live contact hit in
like three weeks
FS it feels like it's the first day at
training camp exactly like Julian
Edelman running over the middle and
getting getting the spider webs knocked
out I'm fired up now I'm writing myself
a note I'm gonna own you for the rest of
the show
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports